hey
everybody hey deborah i see that you
popped
in right before we went live i'm trying
to get into it right now
yeah because i think she's the only one
in here at the moment
trying to get it just done it says it's
not strange okay
that's all well yeah it's every single
time you say that it's just kind of like
the volume thing he always says it's not
streaming yet because your thing has a
lag on it that's why yeah
all right what the hell today it is
monday deborah's here deborah's only one
here
well now it's okay there's three they're
all starting to come in yeah everybody's
starting to come in now what the hell
day is it today it's monday right yeah
yeah yeah it's monday uh so you want to
just go ahead and start talking about
the movie might as well this
um or do you want to do that because
yeah okay now this movie uh oh i saw
something moving over there and i
thought
i thought it was the kitty but it was
your hand okay
i just saw it out of the corner of my
eye i was like [ __ ] i thought pookie
was back in here running around like
crazy now everybody's saying hi
hi hi bees nice movies hi everybody
uh yeah so this movie i had actually
been wanting to do this one for a while
i didn't
i saw it come up on shutter a few weeks
ago
it i don't know why i didn't watch it i
just wasn't in the mood for it and it's
like it only got it looked like it only
got like a three skull rating and i was
like oh
i don't know maybe it's not any good it
was better than that it was but then
yeah but then the thing i was like i was
kind of going through some lists of like
you know best horror movies of 2020 so
far and stuff like looking for stuff
that we could review for the show
and this came up on like several lists
and i was like oh
what the hell maybe we'll go ahead and
watch it last night because it looked
like
it would be fun like a horror comedy and
so i figured and then since it was
brazilian and
you know you grew up in brazil i thought
it would be something you would enjoy
yeah it's a real good brazilian movie
it's the best brazilian movie i've seen
i mean we don't see a lot of you don't
see a lot of brazilian
horror um no although this is
you know this is definitely a comedy but
it's a comedy in the sense that like
death
or evil dead is a comedy it's uh
this one first of all the guys who made
this knew what they were doing
they they they must be about about our
age
it's seen all the [ __ ] horror
classics it's a [ __ ] throwback movie
in a way
it's taking place now it's about a bunch
you know
is it in portuguese yes it's in
portuguese you want to see it in
portuguese but the subs are
the subs are accurate
it's funny it's fun and it's uh
you know it's an old-school horror movie
kind of like evil dead
practical effects mixed with some some
cgi but the practical effects are
[ __ ] awesome in it
it's [ __ ] funny as hell they took the
premise of
it's fake ghostbusters yeah it's
basically like ghostbusters meets
peter jackson yeah or or sam raimi
yeah they call themselves in portuguese
what would translate to
like [ __ ] not ghost hunters but
kind of like phantom hunters
yeah okay and then they rip off the
ghostbusters [ __ ]
symbols and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's a triangle instead of a circle
though so it's totally not a ripoff
yeah yeah yeah and they're they have a
youtube show
and they go out and they fake hauntings
and try to make money off the [ __ ]
youtube channel they're
like these three losers three or four of
these damn losers
and uh they get involved with this case
at a high school
and they get paid by the
by the principal who doesn't think the
[ __ ] haunting is real
he just wants them to come into a fake
investigation do their show
and then claim that it's cleared to calm
the kids down he's gonna pay him 500
bucks each
yeah and get there they're ready to fake
the whole thing turns out it's a real
[ __ ] haunting
yeah and it's the ghost of [ __ ]
bloody mary
all right um now when i was in brazil
they didn't really have
the bloody mary legend but
evidently they have it now they didn't
call her bloody mary they called her
blonde in the bathroom yeah when i look
when i did the google translate
because that's what you said and i
wanted to check so actually the
brazilian the
american uh you know the english title
is ghost hunters versus bloody mary
yeah um the title in portuguese is more
like
spirit exterminators versus the bathroom
blonde
bathroom blonde blonde of the bathroom
or bathroom blonde
yeah that's how you know that's what
that's what they call it that's what
this
portuguese title yeah and uh
you see but and and they they do the
backstory and everything i don't want to
[ __ ] spoil it
okay but the the brazilian version of
bloody mary
it's like a 13 year old girl from a
private 10 i think
no they said she's 13. oh at one point
they said she was she's 10.
no one guy accused her of being 10.
though okay but she was actually 13.
okay okay because he called her a
pedophile because he's had sex
with a woman who is possessed by the
[ __ ] speech like an old woman that
was an older possession he was trying to
do the math
this is a messed up movie i'm gonna say
okay it's got a typical
brazilian humor it's very very [ __ ]
sexual
it's very very crude very sexual
they [ __ ] race is [ __ ] f
they don't have issues with race in
brazil that's that's [ __ ]
that's fair game so they [ __ ] with
people behind their races and everything
it's hilarious it's hilarious yeah it's
not pc at all
and it's totally totally disgusting
yeah there is um there's lots of go
there's
buckets and buckets and buckets of gore
yeah lots of vomit
yeah um lots of [ __ ] yeah
which made me gag actually yeah um you
know guy has to fight a [ __ ] turd
yeah an animated turd yeah
there's all kinds of vom it's every
[ __ ] there's a killer fetus
there's just don't [ __ ] wreck it the
edit
the edit is [ __ ] very good it's a
very fast-paced
this is the best brazilian movie i've
seen it's a [ __ ]
it's a good movie i liked it and it
wouldn't
if you were to try to you know dub this
movie it would
it would [ __ ] this movie up because
even if you're not really paying
attention to the
like i understand the dialogue the
acting yeah because somebody just
asked if you uh are you fluent enough in
portuguese you watch the movie without
subtitles
yeah yeah um the subtitles were accurate
but if you didn't understand portuguese
and we're just relying on the
on the subs the voice acting is so good
you [ __ ] she was laughing through the
whole [ __ ] thing
yeah that was [ __ ] hilarious yeah and
um
they've seen all the [ __ ] whoever
wrote the movies seen ghostbusters
they've seen evil dead
they've seen all the [ __ ] great
movies they talk about [ __ ] horror
stereotypes
the characters in the movie talk about
horror stereotypes it's kind of
almost kind of like airplane they're
like you know it's just me and you
together and then horror movie
we should be doing drugs or having sex
and then just that kind of [ __ ]
well yeah because i think the way they
approach it at the beginning
is like i said there's these four losers
and they live i mean i love
that they live in the back of this of
one of them's dad's
butcher shop it's his dad right or his
uncle or something um
his uncle yeah i think it's his uncle
and they live behind there and they
don't pay any rent and they're like a
bunch of bombs they're just like trying
to
make money off youtube not get real jobs
and they're trying to like make
money off this youtube channel but all
they do and they've been doing it didn't
they say you've been doing it for like
20 years
yeah or something like that had been
like a really long time
it's three guys and it's one girl the
girl's like one of those like flaky
psychic type
chicks yeah and they're trying to get
hits off her cleavage and [ __ ]
get youtube hits they put her head on
the [ __ ] mo
another in one of the promos they put
her head on another body
that had bigger cleavage trying to get
more hits she got pissed she was
terrible
disgusting so she said you know just
[ __ ] it's hilarious and the uniforms
that then the uniform that they get for
her is very funny too
yeah i think i i kind of love like i
like the character i guess
evidently um i wouldn't know but
apparently like
at least like the main guy or maybe like
the top three guys were like kind of
well-known comedians in brazil
yeah um so i don't they didn't have
anything to do with writing it or
anything like that but they
definitely got like comedians for this
and this is yeah it's not a horror movie
betting the stretch of the imagination
other than it being like just
over the top disgusting and revolting
with like just gore and
puke and [ __ ] and everything everywhere
but it has the but it's just
it's funny it's it's a it's mostly a
comedy it's it's very crude it's very
crass
yeah um you know what i mean there's a
lot of just a lot of [ __ ]
gore cannibalism yeah like i said
there's like
yeah poop i mean yeah how can you not
love a movie that actually has the line
not today mr poop yeah
the monster the monster course bloody
mary she's
uh that probably about the cutest little
like
probably 10 12 13 year old brazilian
blonde girl that you can imagine she's
[ __ ] super cute
she's dressed in a damn sailor outfit
and then they got this [ __ ] badass
spooky makeup on her she does a really
good job in the movie
she's actually really good at this yeah
you see her with her without the
the um she's a german brazilian that
it's funny you know when you see the
cast here you you when you see him
there's a lot of stereotypes about how
brazilians look
but you see him you can see why i went
there when i when i grew up there people
did not believe that i was american they
thought i was brazilian
yeah so well there's not one brazilian
no
it's multi it's kind of that's kind of
like saying there's one american
american yes
it's multi-ethnic and there's anglos and
there's germans there and people of
irish descent
the one of the main characters last
name's jackson you know they have a lot
there's a lot of confederates after the
[ __ ] civil war
ran to brazil there's a whole [ __ ]
community of them down there in the
south
so you know when i was living there most
people just thought i was from the south
of brazil but
um they they made a joke in this one too
about like the one kid who was
your head in japanese he was a
red-headed asian kid yeah
and that that's true too the largest
japanese population outside of japan is
in brazil
yeah and they have a huge it's called
liver dodgy that's a that's the towns
it's a town inside sao paulo it's a it's
a neighborhood inside of sao paulo
and liver dodgy was set up by a bunch of
japanese who had run from
the japanese dictatorship world war ii
but they had a bunch of tongs there they
had another
the black dragon society yeah or they
said it was called i think it was
well that wasn't that wasn't that count
dante that's calm down but there was a
real black dragon
yeah that's right that's right it was a
yakuza society that was helping the
emperor fight america
during world war ii that was there i um
but uh it's funny because like they do
have like
red-headed japanese people yeah i think
that would happen
yeah yeah you'll see and there's one of
them in the movie
and he's like i like that they
introduced that character he doesn't
really get introduced until later but
it does kind of like play up because he
was kind of a kid who was like a fan of
theirs
yeah and i guess it was him that got the
principal to bring
the thing because he was his friend that
got because the whole bloody mary thing
in the movie like you said
you know when you lived there they
didn't have that they didn't really have
that legend
if they had it if they had it i didn't
hear about it
the one where you like in the mirror and
you see her like you're like candy man
or whatever
i think maybe they had something like
that
maybe they did have that that seems like
i mean i don't know but that seems like
a pretty
universal maybe they did have that uh
urban legend
i mean everywhere that i've heard of has
a variation of
or something like it they didn't call
her bloody mary
yeah they may have had something like
that it was just a woman you see in the
mirror and they didn't have a name but
they obvious they didn't have a name for
her in this
they had to invent that name they just
called her blonde in the bathroom yeah
and she was like meg from [ __ ]
still brazil picks up americanisms over
time through movies
yeah and that's probably where they got
it it
that's that's an american thing i think
yeah
well and somebody pointed out and i was
just gonna say too that it might be that
uh after candyman came out in the early
90s
that that urban legend might have
proliferated even more
i don't quite i don't remember that i
don't remember anybody mentioning
anything about saying anything in the
mirror and seeing a woman
i think it's i think it's really
interesting though that i mean because
you know portuguese and because the
english shuttle was bloody mary because
that's what she's usually called in the
u.s
but you know you said that's not what
they're calling her
and even when i looked at up the title
because i looked at the brazilian or the
portuguese title as well and it's
definitely the bathroom blonde or the
blonde in the bathroom it's what they're
saying
and she has a name her name's katarina
but that's
it's just funny that they decided to
call her bloody mary because i guess if
they called her the blonde in the
bathroom though nobody know they were
talking nobody would know what they were
and that doesn't really sound like a
horror that's what brazilians are
talking about though
yeah a lot of nobody which means they're
blonde in the bathroom and that's what
they [ __ ] kept calling her that's
what they called her and it's because
bloody mary would be like
would be maria sangriosa
which sounds way cooler actually now
that you mention it
yeah but maybe when they heard the
[ __ ] tale
they didn't never heard that they didn't
hear the name of it
just the concept they kind of was
sitting in the moment
three three times in the dark and it
comes through yeah in this one you not
only had to say her name in the mirror
you also had to knock
on the door of the bathroom stall three
times and flush the toilet three times
yeah and they go into why that is like
they go into a little bit of her
backstory and everything
sanders said i like bloody berries the
liquid ones yeah i do as well
matter of fact i have some zing zang in
the refrigerator still i haven't had a
bloody mary in a while although there's
not a lot in there i'd have to make like
a little bitty one
maybe i could have might be have some
day drinking going on
a little bit of bloody mary in
celebration of this movie
but yeah so i will say that i mean i
think my favorite character in this one
was uh
was the guy that they were just
constantly [ __ ] on all the time
you know what i mean yeah who was whose
uncle was like the guy that
you know where the room behind where
they were staying it's like that way it
went
bloody mary might be maria sangria yeah
but which also sounds like booze it is
booze
that's why they don't use it maybe
that's why because everyone would say
scary about so they're fighting a
cocktail yeah yeah that's that
that's yeah that's a cocktail that's
probably why they don't that's the next
trauma versus a killer cup
that means it's a wine sangria is a wine
but that's
spanish i i don't latin language is a
kind of
bloody i don't uh man yeah
some sangriosa sangria somebody elsa
i think they might have another term for
bloody in portuguese
i mean my my [ __ ] vocabulary is a
vocabulary of a teenager
yeah and i haven't used it because you
haven't been there but yeah and i
haven't used it in a long time
i mean you he remembers it because i can
understand it but you have some friends
there too that you
talk to occasionally so right but the
thing is is that i speak in english to
them and they speak in portuguese to me
because we all
speak well we all understand english
yeah and we all understand portuguese
yeah well educated brazilians all know
english you can at least read or write
it
or understand it if they don't speak it
that's really that's something that i
always found really interesting too is i
feel like a lot of
um europeans and stuff like that
whatever their main language is most of
them at least
understand yeah i mean a lot of them are
fluent in english but a lot of them at
least understand like
you know what's funny is that a lot of
them that i grew up with
they didn't speak english at the time
but they do now
because that was weird you know and then
some of them are here
almost all the girls that i grew up with
are here now yeah they're all women in
their 40s and 50s
their families do whatever they can to
get them out of there and
well two i think it's um there's more
incentive for people to learn english
just particularly because
you know american pop culture is so
prevalent around yeah and you know
there's a lot of people you know i want
to say something about [ __ ]
immigration and [ __ ]
people always thinking about well you
know people from all around the world
should come here
it's good for america you can look at it
that way but you know it's
the immigration was terrible for brazil
it was just it was nothing but just a
brain drain all their best people left
yeah that's fine brazil up yeah that
does happen
the the the um the the you know [ __ ]
the the best thing a brazilian could do
is to leave brazil that's a [ __ ] bad
situation
that's a bad way of doing it it was
[ __ ] very bad for brazil
well you were we were talking about that
too just in uh
regards to the us like in like smaller
rural towns
um or some even some whole states in the
us where
if there's not a lot going on there if
there's not a lot of industry there that
they're going to be a brain drain as
well because
you know the young people are going to
hang around you know and
stay in these tiny little towns and they
don't think they can get anywhere with
it so they're going to move somewhere
else yeah and then they leave brazil and
then they come here to the united states
and just get chewed up and spit out
by our corporations you know it's just
it's when had they stayed in brazil
oh we all do yeah it's almost kind of
like a modern form of importing slaves
because the rich people don't give a
[ __ ] about you they're going to get you
here
depress the [ __ ] wages chew you up
and spit you out replace you with a
robot eventually
yeah that's that's the system
speaking of crazy [ __ ]
the uh the jud one of the judges who was
in charge of a [ __ ]
the case about the the child island man
um her family got [ __ ] shot up today
and then a few hours later another
[ __ ] lawyer involved in that same
case he got assassinated
and it was just like i said earlier
another show they came up
dude was dressed as a [ __ ] fedex
federal ex federal express
mail driver yeah yep ran the doorbell
and opened it she [ __ ] he shot the
son
pow and then the [ __ ] husband bow let
her live and then he [ __ ] left
and then they got another one child
island man
and uh they didn't kill a judge
you know why they didn't kill the judge
they just put a new judge they're gonna
they tried to scare that judge
yeah that's why they're trying to send
us trying to send a message
not to [ __ ] convict any child island
man's [ __ ] customers
it's really weird because i was just
reading about a case from 2001
because i was looking into it for my for
the book i'm writing
um of a dude thomas wales
and he actually got assassinated in
2001. he was a district attorney or
something like that
um they think he might have been shot
either because of some
case he was working on because some
high-profile airline pilot or because he
was an anti-gun advocate but they
they um he he it was a professional hit
they know that somebody just like shot
him through the window
yeah but i was just it's weird that i
was just reading about that i wouldn't
said something if i was uh if i was uh
in
in child island man's clique i would uh
i would frame trump i would say that
trump put the hit out to defend himself
that's how i would play it
do i think he did no i don't think he
did i don't i don't think trump has a
strength to [ __ ] put a hit on anybody
people kind of have this [ __ ]
misconception that trump is a strong
president trump is a weak president
you know i agree with a lot of what he's
doing he's a weak president um
he's surrounded by people that don't
cooperate with him the pentagon hates
him
the top parts of the republican party
hate him all the democrats hate him he
he's basically the entire [ __ ]
systems against him i'm [ __ ] i can't
believe he's survived as long as he has
um if if trump had the power to put hits
out on people he would have done it
already he'd be winning
because if i was in his position i'd
have killed half him people up there by
now
they're lucky i'm not the president
they're all lucky
you're all looking lucky first thing i
would do is i don't think that would go
well
i would cut a deal with the mexican drug
cartels have them come in here as my
private army
and then i could deny it so i don't know
don't vote for me i'd have the [ __ ]
median drug cartel in here cooking your
children
that's not cool dude don't say that live
why are you even talking about this
because if i was we were talking i would
be the emperor we were talking i would
be the embassy this is why
this is the only reason i didn't want to
do live stream because i was just kind
of like well we're talking about a fun
movie and all of a sudden he's talking
about like killing it as a people
so you know that's nice i would become
the emperor
if you think so okay no i was trying to
read like some of the comments like
before you went off on your
uh you know fantasy there but um
which like i said i don't want to get
demonetized but you know
too late now probably um yeah somebody
said
uh moped problems said they did have the
bloody mary legend when i was a kid
right around the time candy man the
movie came out
and they called her bloody mary kids
also improvised
evidently said kids also improvised and
said the mirror thing worked with freddy
krueger which okay fair enough this is
in brazil
i don't know okay ask i'm asking him
and then sanders said uh in germany all
of us almost all of us learned english
at school that's what i thought i
thought pretty much everybody learned
other languages which is weird because i
mean it's been a long time since i was
in high school but
you didn't have to learn a foreign
language
in high school you didn't have to take a
foreign language you did if you wanted
to go to college because i took
three or four years of french of course
i don't remember any of it
really but other than a word here and
there sometimes i'll watch a movie in
french and be like hey i know what that
means but you know
i took spanish for a few years too but
that was like a long time ago
he said no that was in the bronx new
york yeah because
like i said i think bloody mary is a
pretty well known i mean i think it's
called other things like in other
areas of the us but yeah i was just
talking about that legend
in in brazil i don't think brazil had it
well like i said i remember it i mean
american movies have proliferated
so much around the world that probably
any legend that they talk about in an
american movie
if that movie gate gets any kind of
traction in another country it's people
are gonna
yeah come up with their versions of it
well evidently now they do they just
don't call her that yeah
blonde in the bathroom it's funny how
they didn't like really come up with
a funny name like a cool name for her
that that's
like what they called them yeah that
tells me it's something that that
that they picked up as an americanism
they picked up
yeah and bloody mary that the
translation would have been like you
said
some wine yeah so they didn't so they
just used
it was that chicken in the bathroom
wines she must be american
[Laughter]
something like that the killer blonde in
the mirror
yeah but i thought it was great movie
though
it was super fun i thought like i said
you know if you're really
into like super gory disgusting crass
kind of [ __ ] like dead alive or evil
dead or something like that it should be
right up your alley i thought it was
hilarious i mean just the it just got
more and more
ridiculous like as it went on and it was
just obviously having a really good time
with it
um not for the weak stomach that's for
sure
although the only part that grossed me
out was the was the third part
because i can't i can't watch anything
to do with like [ __ ] [ __ ]
hernandez said the mexican cartel's
already here yeah i know they're already
here
it's just that as the united states
[ __ ] declines
and starts to break apart during its
[ __ ] eventual demise
[ __ ] usually what ends up happening
is you have kind of like a damn
we're already in like the roman imperial
phase where you have all the rich people
and all the [ __ ] political parties
doing assassinations on each other and
then you know
hiring barbarian armies to come in and
handle business
because the state is so corrupt and weak
and so divided you can't get anything
done you got to hire foreigners to do it
it's only a matter of time before it
goes that way you know you guys know i'm
i'm patriotic i fought for the united
states as one of its soldiers and stuff
i at one time believed in a lot of its
values
i don't really believe in its values
anymore i don't think they're a real i
don't think it's realistic
not with the society you have today it's
just gonna [ __ ]
collapse kind of like the soviet union
did um
the good thing about it is that the
united states is made up of states
and the state governments a lot of them
are still real strong
they'll just survive as independent
countries and make new coalitions and
stuff
but it's just it's just too damn big
there's too many political differences
there's too many different [ __ ]
and if you look at what's happening
right now what's moving to the
forefront is ethnonationalism you know
everything's being divided up by race
blm is an ethno-nationalist
movement when you you can you can
interpret it that way if you want
uh and it will just continue to fragment
along [ __ ] racial lines probably and
that was really gonna [ __ ] up elections
you just
there's too many damn people and you
can't get them to all agree on the same
things
you're not going to get them to agree on
the same [ __ ] values
the same laws and they're not going to
they're not going to [ __ ]
they're not going to believe any of
these election results from here on out
it's just
gonna it's the system's poisoned
and it's just gonna continue to get
worse uh
i think the safest thing to do is just
let it break apart into different
regions
that would be the safest thing you you
don't want to waste your resources and
your blood trying to hold this [ __ ]
together
i don't think americans want to be in
the same country anymore not anymore
that's just my take on it
jenny doesn't jenny wants to stay
totally neutral on this she doesn't
believe it but
no i'm just saying that's just what i'm
seeing
okay but we were doing a movie review
okay anyway
our movies on shutter movies we already
did the review
and i'm hungry so i'm gonna go eat okay
all right we'll probably be back
tomorrow probably do another movie
review
or whatever we think of doing so again
thanks for dropping by
and we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow see ya